hey guys my name is markiplier I've got
a very important announcement we're
gonna be doing a charity livestream for
Save the Children starting tomorrow at
10 a.m. Pacific Standard Time but this
isn't gonna be a normal charity
livestream this one is bigger and better
than anything we've ever done before
I've been setting up the livestream
equipment all day we've been like
collecting the necessary materials to be
able to do all of the challenges that we
have in store and it's gonna be more fun
than just normal challenges because
we've got all this stuff that we're
gonna be doing in front of you and lying
we're gonna be making breakfast with a
twist we're gonna be dodging arrows
we're gonna be on going on an Easter egg
hunt with shock collars we're gonna play
Django with muscle stimulators we're
gonna be playing cards against humanity'
we're gonna be doing an ice bath reading
your comments we're gonna be doing
blindfold friend yoga which is just
something that I made up doesn't even
exist we're gonna be doing body our glow
pens and on top of all of that I've got
a board 24 unique punishments because
every milestone that we reach we're
going to be doing another punishment and
every loser of these challenges that we
got here we're going to be doing another
two punishment and if we hit milestones
in time we even got five additional
unlockable punishments here that you can
see us suffer through but more
importantly above all else above the
punishments above the challenges this
one is extremely important because this
one's for Save the Children which is a
very important charity by itself but
also an anonymous donator has agreed to
match every donation made up to two
hundred thousand dollars and two hundred
thousand dollars is our goal this time
around which if you know is higher than
it's ever been before which is why it's
so important that you guys join us on
this charity livestream tomorrow and not
only that it's so important that you
spread the word
about it we've planned this whole day of
fun and amazing horrible terrible things
that we have in store for you here but
it's gonna be a lot of fun and for a
great cause because everything that you
donate tomorrow everything that you do
tomorrow is double every other viewer
that you get in the stream that can
possibly donate that effect is
compounded every donation that you make
is managed to the entire stream every
action that you take to try to make this
world a better place is gonna be doubled
tomorrow so please join us for a day
full of fun we're all gonna be here and
it's gonna be nonstop so thank you
everybody so much for watching all the
available information is down in the
description below and so hopefully we
will see you tomorrow so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next video
bye guess Bob we're gonna be Bobby by
the way nice bunny Bob apples great okay